the jurgen experience i saw the one guy
uh who got dequeued right yeah yeah
that's brutal just a straight knee to
the face while you're on the ground
yeah super unfortunate and one of his
coaches was yelling just punch is just
punches
marcos tomato who's uh the his name his
nickname is the
jiu jitsu coach one of the coaches for
american top team and he's yelling out
just punches just punches
and then someone else in the coach is
yelling
russian in russian they're you know they
yell onto pyotr
to hit him and you know because he's
thinking that the guys
it's confusing to some fighters when is
a downed opponent
a grounded opponent is technical i'm
sure if he's hunched over it's like wait
is his foot
is his knee down or well if you have one
here's the thing if you have your feet
down but one hand down you're not
grounded
if you have two maybe nevada's still
nevada uses a hybrid version of the
new uh mixed martial arts rules it used
to be
um anytime you had a hand down at all
you were a grounded opponent
and then they switched it to if you have
two hands down you're grounded opponent
but if you have a knee down you're a
grounded opponent so he had a knee and
two hands yeah so he was he was [ __ ]
grounded yeah i mean it was like there
was no question about he was grounded
but
i think maybe he thought he was coming
up and peyote tried to catch him
catch him as he's coming up but he was a
hundred percent illegal yeah
i mean that's so you can see it here see
he oh see he's got one hand down
yeah i think he's got one hand no it
doesn't have both of his hands
hands up so maybe that's what he thought
maybe it was because the knee was down
and both hands were up he thought he
wasn't grounded
yeah maybe that's why he was confused
but i mean
it's 100 percent sucks for both of them
see if if you
you hear your coach yelling hit him see
see even i'm
like thinking like okay is that grounded
or is not grounded
i know it's not i know it's grounded
because this has come up before
because it used to be that when your
hands were down then it was grounded
yeah but then big john mccarthy
explained to me no no
anything other than the surface of your
feet on your legs like so your knee if
your knee is down
that means you're a grounded opponent
like with that guy like is he coming
over from a different fighting league
no he's the champion no he's the
champion it's just
there's different versions of the rules
right in some places
uh a grounded opponent you
what is the new version of the the rule
does it one of the new versions of the
rule
is if you are putting weight on your
hand so like you can
touch it but you can't if you have
weight on it then you're a grounded
opponent but if you're just touching
that's that's not a grounded opponent
all right that's it's all it's too
complicated
as soon as you allow opinion to come in
it's like
well then there's the debate on like was
that the right call bad call it's like
just
set up a clear definitive rule right
well there's other folks that also think
well why isn't that a legal technique
well how come you could punch him in the
face you can't name him in the face this
is stupid
like why can't you get how come he can't
kick him in the face how come when a
guy's lying in his back
he can kick you in the face but you
can't kick him in the face like that
seems stupid too
from 2018 to nevada rules on it does the
new the nevada
has a hybrid version that didn't adopt a
new grounded rule i think
unless they've changed it since then
yeah i think this is to be considered
grounded
it says a more technical piece than new
rules pertains to
that of a grounded opponent which states
a fighter must have both of their hands
down on the ground whether it's be palms
or fists
for them to be considered grounded
unless a knee or anything other than the
soul's kicks
or knee strikes to the head of a
grounded striker or fighter rather
therefore is illegal however the nevada
state athletic commission will not be
adopting this part of the new rules
and we'll stick with the old definition
for a grounded fighter which means
anything but the souls of the feet
okay so that's why it's confusing so
the grounded opponent thing the fighter
must have both their hands down the
ground that's what it used to be
whether it be palms or fists for them to
be considered grounded
unless a knee or other than the soles of
the feet are down as well
so either way he was grounded because
there was a knee down
so it was a illegal technique all over
the world
that one that move which is unfortunate
i mean that's going to suck for him of
like
he was winning the fight too that that's
what sucked um piotr young was
uh he it looked like he was starting to
gain control of the fight and i think it
was in the fourth round was it the
fourth round
it was a good fight though really good
fight and i'm sure they're gonna have a
rematch and the rematch would be super
hyped up and yeah
you know but he had dropped al jamaine
and he had taken him down and tripped
him slammed into the ground a few times
and
it looked like he was in control of the
exchanges but but still
very good fight catch new episodes of
the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience